welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab podcast I'm Michael Cole
Orion who the hell is this guy I am John
Phillips the new gadget lab editor Wow
glad somebody told me John started at
Wired this week how do you like it I
love it it's a it's a trip it's a
culture shock slowly getting acclimated
and but I'm enjoying everything and your
first day we had some pretty big news
which was that's right iphone 4s oh and
by the way why are you wearing those
glasses these glasses are protective
glasses for a laser i'm going to show
off in a few minutes okay so you're
saying there's a laser in the iphone no
there's not a laser in the iphone
there's a laser right here there's a lot
of other cool stuff in the iphone iphone
4s which was the big news this week are
you going to get one i am getting one
tomorrow so I'm gonna wake up ASAP
hustle down to stonestown because I
think I have a better chance of getting
one quicker at stonestown rather than
downtown and apple store all right and
oh yeah we have a luxury of several
Apple stores within the metropolitan
area and suburbs of san fran so my go-to
is stone stone it's just a little bit
more out of the way up secure it should
work out well i'm more of a berlin game
man oh yeah where's Sam Mateo I want to
say house yeah sort of um so is that
something you'd recommend people do look
if you live in a big city maybe not try
to go to the big one where you know all
the fanfare is and all the TV cameras
are me to go to a smaller store yeah I
mean especially if you live in San
Francisco everyone is going to go down
to the downtown store not only to get
the phone but just to be part of the big
you know shindig waiting in line and you
know talking about your new phone
getting excited about what it's going to
offer so what are you excited about what
it's going ok so I am buying the phone
so number 1 i'm excited about Siri which
is the voice recognition software and so
you everyone's probably seen this
already but you could turn on serie ask
her
question her it what we want to call it
ask Syria question and with pretty
amazing accuracy or clarity the computer
in effect will speak back to you or
response so that's what the big deal is
about me personally I want it for text
messaging so I'm one of those guys I
cannot do the thumb texting I need to
tap it out that doesn't work my life is
all auto correction hell and so what I'm
looking forward to is just simple voice
control where I could text out a message
and and do this repeatedly during the
night when my girlfriend is at home and
i'm at home and she refuses to use a
telephone it all has to be text so so
you can really get my get you could
dictate to the phone and then you can
also have Siri read back messages that
you know that's a good question i don't
i want to be able to dictate but i'll
but read back myself all right well I
guess we'll find out pretty soon I
should anyone on Friday and Friday and
it also has a killer improved camera so
that's exciting it's going up to eight
megapixel has a much better low lighting
response so you can you know when you
use your current iphone 4 you shoot it
in a room like a studio like this when
the lights are turned down you don't get
anything and so hopefully the new camera
will allow for much better image quality
in low light situations so you can look
forward to seeing a lot of pictures of
John speaking into his phone in the low
light situations on gadget labs coverage
that'll be awesome and also you can read
our full review of not only the iphone
4s but also the accompanying update to
iOS 5 which is for the most recent iOS
devices so iphones and ipads and you can
read both of those at the product review
section of wired so now i think this
time you put on those cheesy glasses
right Lee's well I think you need to put
some on too okay night let's let's pause
for a second and put on our protective
gear okay
these are stupid dorky glasses and that
is a really cool laser right okay so
this is the wicked lasers Krypton it
this model is a 1 watt green laser and
so laser pointer you might get at the
hardware store is going to be 3
milliwatts this is one full wat it is
notorious for looking like a lightsaber
it does look like a lightsaber looks
very much like a lightsaber and a wicked
got a little bit of trouble if only
briefly for it looking like a lightsaber
but the real cool factor of it is very
apparent when you turn it on so it has
safety locks on it so this is how you do
it you hit this button that sort of
loads it and then you have to hit a
sequence of touch commands to actually
turn it on OIC blinking at you so it's
blinking and the commands are three
quick taps and then two long ones so
let's try it out okay there it is right
when it turns on it starts strobing to
get rid of that you could do a tap and
then to turn it on to full strength and
keep in mind this is about twenty
percent strength that we're going to
about to turn it on to a hundred percent
strength that's a hundred percent
strength that's spectacular so I'm going
to just shoot this around a little bit
what are you doing with this okay
killing ants you could kill ants very
quickly and there's a whole subculture
of that of laser enthusiasts and if
you're a hardcore laser enthusiasts
you're going to use it for balloon
popping experiments and an action figure
experiments and so you can burn I can't
imagine what you could do with an action
figure with that you can burn our
friends hand pretty quickly with it you
want to if you want to destroy your
action figure collection blu popping you
could set off you could like matches
there are a few practical applications
for something like this so if you're
running a search and rescue mission i'm
on one ridge and your run another and
we're looking for a third person who's
lost in the wilderness all the way over
there two miles if i see that person I
could literally point to that rig
and get on a walkie-talkie and say Mike
we found him and then you're saying well
where do I go I say follow the beam
right and yeah and if you are worried
about getting lost in the wilderness you
could take this with you outside
according to wicked lasers it has a
range of 85 miles and so you could
actually hit things in space with this
beam it is a very dangerous device
nonetheless it will burn things if you
hold it on your on your skin for any
prolonged exposure you'll feel the heat
very quickly and of course if you aim it
in someone's eye you're going to cause
retinal damage blindness so one other
words what happens if you aim it at an
ant let's say just in my kitchen for
example the ants it's it's going to stop
and immediately die and today I like and
very quickly shrivel up okay right even
better right service is a warning to all
the other handsome i get right um you
know damn problem I this might be my
solution right what do you how do you
feel about spiders spiders cool cool
spiders okay what's up with these with
these little lenses you have here ok so
the lenses if you want to buy an
optional kid I think its twenty nine
dollars you could screw on these lenses
right on top there and essentially their
special effects lenses so one lens takes
the beam and spreads it out over a wide
plain another lens takes that same
effect but doubles it for sort of like a
cross pattern and then one lens I think
it might be called the starlight filter
sort of creates a hundred or more mini
laser lights in effect you shine it in
the sky it looks like you have thousand
points of light and then there's a few
lenses that sort of have a more
dispersing effect so you could use the
laser almost like a flashlight so yeah
it's crazy piece of technology really
expensive it's a thousand dollars of wat
so it's a thousand-dollar device or the
dollar or wat yeah sorry it's right
dollar wat thousand dollars for this
particular model and you know what I
think it's less expensive to buy that
than to continue buying raid for the
rest of my life feels right
and so much more fun right anyway that
is the wicked lasers Krypton now we're
going to go out to the park and look at
a couple of wicked party devices that do
not involve lasers sadly but does
involve some cool technology gotcha this
is the double nest hammock by eagles
nest outfitters it's a hundred percent
nylon measures about six feet in width
by nine feet in length so you can fit
two people in it comfortably it holds up
to 400 pounds and packs down to the size
of a softball and weighs 22 ounces so if
you want to go backpacking you can stick
in your pack or if you just want to hang
out in the park and drag along with you
the double nest costs 60 495 but it's a
lot easier to set up with the optional
$20 straps basically nylon webbing that
you can wrap around a tree and then clip
to and it's a lot more comfortable than
sleeping on the ground it's really
strong I had no problems with it except
for having to find the right distance
between two trees to set it up to the
right height
a few things go with a hammock like a
nice cold beer
the problem is if you've got an open
beer in your lap when you're in a
hammock it's not gonna be long before it
ends up all over the place which is why
Stanley's 1913 a carbonated drink holder
comes in so handy it comes with domed
ends so it can handle the pressure of
holding your carbonated drink and a wide
mouth opening for easy pork and it makes
for a lot more mess free drinking so
this guy runs for 28 bucks and it's
basically the classy man's brown bag hi
Kristina hi Mike what you got there
today I've got the grid 10 tablet from
fusion garage now this tablet has kind
of a funky history right it does so
fusion garage made this funky juju
tablet last year the year before and it
was just terrible so this is sort of the
back to the drawing board kind of thing
for them it is it's a 2 based on Android
and but they've reskinned everything
it's not like any other two enjoyed
tablet on the market how so so let's
give it a whirl so apps are arranged in
clusters and you can move them around
change their name change their shape
kind of like Tetris pieces kind of
interesting but not entirely efficient
to navigate so are those all apps on
there a lot of these are links to pages
in the web browser but you can download
apps from the amazon appstore so like i
noticed this when i was playing with it
like I clicked on Twitter went to the
tour website i clicked on facebook it
went to the facebook website and when i
was in the browser i noticed the browser
was kind of buggy and i had a hard time
but like the search interface i had a
hard time changing urls things like that
it's very esoteric it kind of uses its
own language it does and I actually got
stuck and I had to come to you for help
because I couldn't figure out how to get
out of a nap back to the home screen
right and so that's something different
from other tablets there's no home
button
or like Android normally has four
buttons on the front of the device no
buttons so what you do to get back to
the home screen is a two-finger swipe
down from the top I see if you want to
go to your notifications it's two swipes
from the right and if you want to go
back it's two swipes to the left which
in this case took us back to the home
screen so this is this a new language
for for tablets I mean I've only ever
used ones with buttons mm-hmm it is
different you get used to it as long as
you realize that you do have to do these
two button swipes okay so it's all so
it's basically sort of reminiscent of
like something like webos mmhmm yeah the
touchpad the the defunct touchpad so a
sort of a bizarre interface a little bit
rough around the edges a little bit
buggy what does this have going forward
price the price is good it's three
hundred dollars for the Wi-Fi version
four hundred dollars for 3g okay it's
available now and it's a big screen most
of the tablets you've seen they're
cheaper than that or eight seven or
eight inches like a kindle or the some
of the other some of the other eight and
seven inch tablets we've seen right it
has a 1366 x 768 display okay so a
couple hundred dollars cheaper than the
ipad would you buy one in place of an
ayah pen probably not i would probably
spring for the extra couple hundred
bucks for the ipad or just wait and get
a kindle fire or keep it around to kill
ants totally we're going to come back
next week Mike Isaac will be back to
show us some stuff that he saw down at
at ctia conference in San Diego and
until then we will see you next time on
gas alot
you